comme un mensonge que tous les conducteurs se disent que la
mort est quelque chose qui
arrive aux autres quel genre de
personne fait un travail comme celui-ci chaque année
deux d'entre nous meurent James de Villiers Calum
Nick est un génie qui monte les voitures
j'accepte chaque fois que j'obtiens le  mecha
il y a 20% de chances que je puisse mourir en étant
conduit à environ 170 miles par heure
cette chose est une bombe sur roues je suis
plus rapide que vous tous faisons la course
je me sens responsable de ce qui s'est passé
vous ne leur feriez pas confiance en regardant vos
courses de fenêtres vous étiez également
responsable  pour m'avoir ramené dans la
voiture je suis champion du monde sur le point de
redevenir champion du monde fais le battre
ce gars crois moi
c'est une merveilleuse façon de vivre c'est la
seule façon de
conduire plus tu es proche de la mort plus
tu te sens vivant
vous